ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together live here on the Rich Eisen
show none other than Deontay Wilder good
to see you again right here on the Rich
Eisen show the WBC heavyweight champion
bronze bomber sitting right here live on
the show good to see you how are you sir
good to see you as well that's great
that's last time I saw you was on the
set of billions yeah man where you were
in the ring with dollar bill or Murphy I
forget which ones definitely most
definitely you know we had I had a great
time that was fun wasn't with all the
cast you know they get to give people
another side of me to see ya as instead
of the bronze mummy inside the boxing
ring right how are you feeling right now
I'm feeling amazing you know the
preparation for camp has has been great
you know I have people you know after
the first fight you know it was a
controversial draw and everything that
occurred in there me knocking him down
him getting up you know it gave people
some type of expectation of what to
expect in the second fight because the
first fight lived up to the height
yesterday sacrifice devil gonna live up
to it as well
in Vegas on Saturday February 22nd I
mean obviously after this game there's
the NBA all-star game and of some
significant interest and then there's
your main event with Tyson Fury yeah to
me when he came on my show I thought
this is a large human being to you do
you even think that - yeah he's pretty
tall I mean you know his height is is
yeah he's tall and he's he's wide as
well - so you think you can definitely
you know we stand in the next to him you
can feel the height
yeah no difference so what do you think
yeah for sure but you know it's I love
it though I love a challenge
I love to get in that each and every
time to display my greatness right I
always say we all have greatness in us
but greatness is only determined by
service so I like to I'd like to apply
my service to my greatness ed and I
displayed each and every time in the
ring and no matter the opponent is short
at all I'm gonna get in my best I'm
gonna give you my heart
a gladiator sport it's a warrior sport
and that's what we display each and
every time we put out a life on the line
for others entertainment and I love to
do it I'd say if you love to do
something that you do every day or
whatever then it's not work and for us
it's not really work is just us enjoying
each other releasing each other energy
so when you knocked him down kiante how
many seconds do you think he got was
giving to get up I think you got more
more time than didn't eat it you know
even the referee said that he went out
for the spirit of boxing and not just
not just not not the rules that he did
what was best for boxing but I would
tell him sir that's not your job your
job is simple you know my my
two-year-old can do it is the count you
know and unfortunately you have to count
someone out and you know I you know with
it being so exciting to fight being so
big you know he made an emotional
decision you know and I felt but on the
other hand it was a controversial
decision as well which you know it made
for great fighter in me you know the
height in the expectation for the second
fight even better so it's like it's like
a give-and-take kind of thing it's like
you know so so we took that and we ran
with him so you know here we are now I
know and we're still talking about it
and what did you think when he did get
up I mean what was that what was that
like Lucas for anybody with a set of
eyes it's quite something I mean it was
a it was it was definitely amazing to
see you know most of the time when I'm
putting people on the canvas
they're not getting up and they buddy do
weird things while it's on there but
this specific time you know he got up
it's you know when looking upon that
because when I dropped him I'm looking
over here I'm sitting his eyes in the
back of his head his vein is pulsing out
of his neck and his body is on the
canvas like a murder scene so when you
see in there it's like you know it's
over I'm kissing I'm blowing kisses at
my wife from June you know doing
different things outside of me to the
audience or whatever and then the turn
around and seeing rise from the dead it
was like it was surprising to me but
inside I was like overwhelm and I was
I was like Hollywood with joy because
this is our event that we're in and the
thing is we want to entertain the people
give them somebody want to see and I
don't think whether you was in the arena
I will you was at home on TV or even
listening to the radio if you wasn't
inside from their fight then I don't
know what what fighter make your side it
was amazing you were there right Chris
you were in the building we were there
I've never seen anything like it
I still can't believe Tyson Fury got up
I thought it was like a 15 count to be
honest Deonte
it was incredible I'm so excited for the
rematch thank you so much you know
they're just uh when I look at him
getting up and it just it shows the
heart and the character in a person what
we really have to dig deep deep up in
this sport you know me and specially
when when when everything is win on you
you on the ground
your body is fatigued and you just gotta
have that thought in mind like I gots to
get up and I think I think it proved the
heavyweight division is back and I think
that boxing has been sorely missing that
from the sport it's on fire you know and
one of the things about he was talking
that he said that he just likes just
went on in that time but to see it rise
and go on like man is just it's one of
those moments in time that I'll never
forget and you respect that right as a
fighter of course deandre because it's a
warrior sport it's a man's man's sport
you got to have to warm your heart and
mentality to do it and you know and you
respect that so much when you step in
the ring and you see how we we put by
the damage to each other you know your
head is not meant to be hit in the first
place you know that exactly where we go
for the first I got a Wilder WBC
heavyweight champion of the world right
here on the Rich Eisen show let's let's
test the respect factor here though
when Tyson Fury was on my show in Los
Angeles a few months ago he said he won
ten of the twelve rounds against you
what do you think of that yeah you know
I don't I don't feel of course I see the
fight differently 'maybe you and anger
was different than that because I felt I
won the first four rounds you
um with that fight you know we all can
say what we want to say what we saw or
what we felt and that what made it you
know a great fight and then what's made
it so controversial rhyme with the
judges they saw it even going in the
12th round I felt like it was gonna be a
tight on minute lead I didn't know time
felt like I was behind right and with
all the tactics of sticking his tongue
out putting his hand behind his back
inside out those are tactics there was a
veteran tactics to win the round you
know when it's indecisive with the judge
and you do those sorts of things and
stuff like that so but you know my
judges was right on point you know I
felt and and they they made a great
decision on how I win because I saw an
even going back you know although I have
to put the fight on mute you know the
conversations would mislead you what do
you mean because because we have
commentators you know when they they
saying crazy stuff in the fight when
they painting their narrative of people
that don't understand boxing and looking
in you know we go mainly for the
newcomer the commentators did so-called
experts yeah that's supposed to be
giving us a proper assessment of the
fight now if they painting the narrative
that ain't so then I gotta bleed and I
gotta believe you know what it's being
said of dumb-butt going back looking at
that fight it was in the case of
whatever you have to go back and render
and put it on mute and make a proper
assessment and adjustment for yourself I
gotta try your fur you don't put me on
me when you watch you can't do that I
mean every putting me on mute you know
it let's take him food off my table at
bronze bomber on both Twitter and
Instagram right here on the right Roger
secure you've got a take on Super Bowl
54 do you got a team that you like here
oh man you know I mean I've been in the
lab working traveling always constant
trying to mix family in so yeah too much
football I haven't I haven't seen you
know we got well you got eight kids and
you're traveling world and stuff like
that you rarely have time for too much
you know most of the time was been on my
TVs word party and
and uh and true so well I mean you're
six seven correct is that correct okay
and you're from Tuscaloosa Alabama born
or raised so did you ever try football
did anybody ever say throw you out there
on the field and as a tight end or
something like that or well yeah just
been being from Tuscaloosa you know it
was you know we've seen football day in
and day out so as a child yeah you want
to do what you see and that was my goal
in plans you know until I was in college
and I had a daughter that was on the way
that was born with spina bifida so you
know it's just like to say like if for
me it's like sometimes when you have
plans because he'll other god help other
plans for you and those players that I
had set for myself
yeah he's seen it in another light a
different way and I found one of my
purpose you know at that point in time
my life coming up having a child I was
born with a disorder you know it was
very tough it was difficult being that
you young yourself and you only pray for
a healthy child and then when you don't
get that you gotta you gotta you gotta
you gotta sent responsibilities and do
what you got to do as a as a human being
in general and as a father you know and
I love being a father you know if it
wasn't for her I wouldn't be in boxing
when you know I'll probably be you know
in football or basketball or something
like that but having her she changed my
world completely and and I'm forever
grateful for it because I wouldn't be in
this position I probably will even be
here who knows where I beat no you know
without my children man their blessings
many people say when you have kids and I
plan that you know there's some mistake
but no child is a mistake you know and I
just love it the father being the
father's number one for me you know even
my two yards understand boxing all my
kids to be at the fight yeah and my to
yo say I want to go see daddy boom boom
so they understand what I do and it's
very appreciative to me because I want
to understand what daddy does and how
severe it is you know I'm saying cuz
like I tell people I'm risking weari
risking my our lives each and every time
to getting out there we don't know if
we're gonna come back insane or whatever
but we love
we love to do it I gotta be honest with
you Deonte again Tyson Fury I wouldn't
imagine wanting to get into any
situation with him at all other than the
one where I was talking to him and when
I did ask him about how whether he had
any time any extra time and getting up
the look he shot me I wouldn't want to
be in any sort of cross-purpose with
that man - the fact that you get in the
ring with him I know you're a you're a
very stout individual yourself but that
is I mean that that is and that's why
everybody's so excited for this fight in
Vegas and on pay-per-view where you can
go to see it in person or go watch it on
February 26 and people just fascinated
by the two of you guys being in the same
ring yeah and I wish you only the best
of luck sir man thank you so much you
know and uh if you guys can make it
February 22nd yeah on Fox
ESPN pay-per-view you know what to do
click that button baby you don't want to
miss this it's gonna be exciting it's
gonna be thrilling just like the first
one you know I never let anyone doubts
when I have an event you know I've been
knocking guys out for 20 years
professionally and you know what to
expect from Deontay Wilder nothing but
greatness like I said I'm providing my
service to my greatness and each and
every time I'm displaying that to the to
the paying customers because I know how
hard it is to pay hard-earned money
especially with society and things
that's going on so I'm very appreciative
I want to say that in advance and I'm
looking forward to an amazing fight the
wild adversity we to baby and what has
to go what happens after it what's your
plan after after the after the fight we
probably have a ever beat celebration or
something like that okay since I already
invited fury as well you know I told him
come apart with us you know as a person
I like them you know as a fighter we
always have to compete against each
other and you know at times they can get
very competitive in the ring and we say
certain things to promote yeah and stuff
like that and that just our emotions
that's getting the best of us out of a
negative energy that we displace so when
we're in the ring we get we have an
opportunity to release
clean saw itself so at the end that's
when we're able to embrace each other
and tell each other we love each other
and kiss each other and say man we happy
we did it it was the best and everybody
going with that happy lies so so while
we're looking at the guest list for your
after party celebration his answer is
Anthony Joshua invited he's invited as
well to the cow the cow huh so he's
still invited he's invited do you think
he'd show you know uh you know I doubt
it
I doubt it buddy you know he's invited
as well too it's gonna be a great it's
gonna be a great moment in time you know
where right now is about me and fury and
I'm looking forward to getting in there
with the old grit again Saturday
February 22nd at the MGM Grand Garden
Arena in Las Vegas Nevada
also available as you mentioned on
pay-per-view none other than Tyson Fury
taking on my guest appreciate you coming
by right here sir Deonte the bronze
bomber Wilder right here when we come
back here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app